[Musique]
c'est un 20 décembre tout particulier
que la réunion fait de cette année les
commémorations et les célébrations ont
dû s'adapter au contexte de la crise
sanitaire actuel département a fait un
grand vin décembre malgré tout avec les
conditions de sécurité sanitaire
maximale pour protéger le public
donc après une journée d'ouverture du
musée de villèle
ce soir on a un concert connectés donc
on aura un grand concert quand même de
davy sicard qui est d'accès gratuit mais
en forme dématérialisée
grâce aux nouvelles technologies le
département a souhaité proposer au plus
grand nombre
un concert de davy sicard retransmis en
direct sur une plateforme dédiée
avec mon équipe nous vivent ça comme un
privilège mais sincèrement nous connaît
que pas tout artiste n'est là l'occasion
jouer en cette période là la fen
confiance dont il est reconnaissant pour
ça et en plus dans la magnifique
l'endroit que les charges et en histoire
donc pour nous ça c'est vraiment un
privilège une parenthèse culturelle et
musicale fortement apprécié par les
réunionnais du monde entier ce moment
suspendu dans le temps et l occasion de
partager et de transmettre un bout de
notre histoire
tout au fond de toi les parts de tous
ces braves au cul pour toi son oeuvre
luc laramée de leurs sacs à galets bien
fusent on joue plus
la plume que je porte la veille